So, da bin ich mal wieder.
Wir haben heute wieder nichts vor, nichts großartig.
Ich bin einfach abends zu kaputt, dass wir noch krasse technische Sachen machen können.
Ich kann mich auch überhaupt nicht konzentrieren abends irgendwelche Sachen zu programmieren
oder irgendwas zu basteln oder sowas, aber im Dezember, wisst ihr was, Dezember, ich muss
noch drei Wochen arbeiten ungefähr dieses Jahr und dann habe ich komplett restliche
Jahr frei.
Ja, und mal gucken wie das nächstes Jahr wird so wegen neuem Job und, oder wegen vielleicht,
vielleicht neuem Job.
Dann muss ich nicht mehr hin und zurück fahren die Woche zweimal nach Frankfurt.
Sondern habe dauerhaft Homeoffice, das heißt ich bin auch auf jeden Fall wieder fitter.
Ja, müssen wir mal gucken.
Mal gucken ob das Geräusche heute weg ist, mal gucken, Acreege, ja, ob das Geräusche
weg ist, wenn nicht, ist wahrscheinlich wirklich mein Herz nicht im Arsch, kann ich nichts
dagegen machen heute.
Und, Chat, was gibt's neues, habe ich irgendwas wichtiges verpasst, Melonman schreibt was
und ich sehe es nicht, was er schreibt, weil der Winkelpippo da vor ist, über die Twitch
API kann man aber kein Chatcommands adden, oder?
Ne, über die Twitch API nicht, Chatcommands unterstützt ja Twitch eh nicht, Chatcommands
gehen über irgendwelche Bots und wenn du ein Bot programmieren willst, dann gibt's eine
eigene Bot-API dafür, du kannst, du kannst den Chat aber mitlesen, achso, ne, wenn du
einfach nur, wenn du einfach nur auswerten willst was im Chat geschrieben wird, das kannst
du komplett ohne API Keys machen, das ist ja dein IRC-Chat unter der Haube, ja, aber
manchmal, manchmal rauscht's ein bisschen, das ist ja dein IRC-Chat unter der Haube,
du kannst sogar komplett ohne Twitch API und sogar ohne Twitch-Account kannst du den Chat
mitlesen und dann musst du einfach nur drauf reagieren, wenn einer irgendwas im Chat schreibt,
was geht, das ist ja ein ganz normaler IRC-Chat, das haben wir sogar irgendwann im Stream schon
mal gemacht, ich hab da auch immer so einen eigenen Chat-Highlighter programmiert, wo
ein Wubblos drinsteht, den benutze ich aber irgendwie nicht mehr, komplett ohne APIs
und sonst was, eine Erbse ist da, moin, achja, ja gut, dann kann ich jetzt dazu was erzählen,
wo wir gerade dabei sind, oh, du hast Corona, und wie geht's dir, also ich muss sagen,
ich war vier, fünf Tage richtig im Arsch, und danach ging's, aber ich war insgesamt
bestimmt zwei, zweieinhalb, drei Wochen ziemlich kaputt, beste Sellout heute, ja, ey, Leute,
zu meinem Sellout, ich sag, ich erzähl euch was zu meinem Sellout, wenn mehr Leute da
sind, falls ich's vergesse, sag Bescheid, dann erzähl ich gleich was zu, ganz okay,
sautrockner Hals, bisschen Gliederschmerren, ja, genau das, das hatte ich auch am Anfang,
es ging dann aber bei mir relativ schnell, es ging relativ schnell bergab, auch mit Fieber
bis 39 und Nase laufen und so und war alles, aber es ging deutlich schneller weg als Erkältung.
Also, die akuten, also diese richtig nervigen Sachen, dafür war man halt dann irgendwie
zwei Wochen voll im Arsch, zwei, drei Wochen voll im Arsch, Fatal, moin, lange nicht gesehen,
schön, dass du wieder da bist, Massive Subscription, ja, 40 Monate, Leute, stellt euch das mal
vor, wer kann sich den Mist hier 40 Monate geben, Pong, ab jetzt bitte in jedem Video
ein Placement, na, so schlimm wird's nicht werden, ja, also, ich sag mal kurz da was
zu, wobei ich sag erst mal was zu meinem Placement, also, wer das Placement heute nicht gesehen
hat, ich hab ein Placement gemacht für Matchmasters, irgend so ein komisches Mobile-Mobile-Pegel-Game,
so, und, das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich, jetzt hab ich ganz vergessen, was ich dazu
erzählen wollte, Kegwaid, ach so, genau, jetzt weiß ich's wieder, also, diese Sachen,
die ich da vorlese, auch schon beim Genshin-Video und auch beim Matchmasters-Video, das läuft
immer folgendermaßen, ja, die Fragen, also, die Fragen, ob ich was, ob ich, ob man Interesse
hat, ja, und ich hab ja mittlerweile jemand, der sich um solche Anfragen kümmert, er handelt
das dann für mich aus, okay, haben wir Interesse, und dann schicken die einem immer ein Briefing,
und in diesem Briefing steht dann zum Beispiel so Sachen drin, wie, erstens diesen QR-Code
experimenten, zweitens die und die Bilder einblenden und sowas in der Richtung, meistens
so, ja, meistens so 5, 6 bis 10 Punkte, worauf man achten muss, und dann gibt's noch ein
bisschen Infos zu dem Game, so, und meistens mach ich's dann so, es ist ja nicht, sag mal
so, Genshin und das ist ja nicht das erste Placement, was ich gemacht hab, normalerweise
mach ich das immer so, ich denk mir dann so ein bisschen was aus, was halbwegs passt,
aber, da bin ich jetzt seit einer Weile weg von, weil ich hab' vor auch ein bisschen
mehr Placements zu machen, das muss ein bisschen entkoppelt, das muss ein bisschen entkoppelt
sein vom Video, also muss man hören, dass ich das den Leuten nicht persönlich empfehle,
so nach dem Motto, Leute, ich spiel das Game rauf und runter, meine persönliche Empfehlung,
das kann ich machen, wenn ich Hetzener Werbung mache, wo ich sag, ich verwende den Kram selbst
schon seit 4, 5 Jahren, oder teilweise sogar schon länger, und ich finde das selbst gut,
das ist was anderes, so, normalerweise sag ich ja dann was, so, was man, mach ich den
Vorschlag, was man sagen könnte, aber, mittlerweile ist es so, dass die relativ starre Skriptvorstellungen
haben, das Skript für Genshin Impact war, ihr werdet also, werdet lachen, aber das Skript
war eine den A4 Seite lang, für 90 Sekunden, lest mal in 90 Sekunden eine A4 Seite vor,
ich mein' es ist nicht in Schriftgröße 5 oder so gewesen, aber es war eine komplette
Seite voll, wo es in 90 Sekunden, was meint ihr, warum ich das Genshin Impact Sponsoring
so runtergerattert hab, und das heute auch, die wollten da wirklich 60 Sekunden gefüllt
mit ihrem Kram, ich hab ihnen was vorgeschlagen, was man alternativ sagen könnte, aber, dann
hab ich dann ein korrigiertes Skript zurückbekommen, weil das nicht Sellout genug war, mein Skript
war halt nicht ganz so cringe, aber ok, und dann denk' ich mir, weißt du, was scheiß
drauf, ich lese den Kram halt einfach vor, wenn ihr das wirklich so wollt, sodass jeder
erkennt, dass es eigentlich Blödsinn ist, aber ihr unbedingt eure 3 Punkte drin haben
wollt anstatt nur 2, ey, ok, mach ich, kein Ding, die bezahlen alle immer ordentlich,
da mach ich das, kein Ding, dann ist es sogar noch besser für mich, weil da bringen es
die Leute mit mir noch nicht mal großartig in Verbindung, was eigentlich auch mal ein
Ziel ist bei diesen Sponsorings in Zukunft, es soll ganz klar sein, deswegen blende ich
es auch immer fett oben ein, es soll ganz klar sein, das ist Werbung, das ist so wie,
was weiß ich, wenn Michael Schumacher, wobei Michael Schumacher macht aktuell, glaub ich,
keine Werbung mehr, so wie wenn irgendwelche Autofahrer, Musikleute und sonst, wenn die
Musik machen, wenn die nicht Musik machen, wenn die Werbung machen, das ist auch kompletter
Blödsinn, letztens hab ich auch eine Werbung gesehen von irgendwelchen Leuten, die irgendwie
was Alpezin oder sowas, Werbung gemacht haben, irgendwelche Profiradfahrer, gut, die fahren
glaub ich in dem Alpezin-Team, aber trotzdem, irgendwelche Profiradfahrer haben Werbung
gemacht hier, because I want to keep my hair, because I want to keep my hair, Alter, die
Typen sind alle irgendwie was zwischen 18 und 30 oder so, die haben keine hair problems,
aber das ist egal, deswegen, das ist halt einfach, ich lese den Kram vor und gut ist, kannst
du Text to Speech das Skript vorlesen lassen, ja, das könnte ich tatsächlich machen, aber
das wollen die bestimmt nicht, die wollen ja immer, dass es eine gewisse persönliche
Note hat, der Witz ist, wenn ich dann selbst einen Text vorschlage, dann wollen die den
immer nicht, gut, dann halt unpersönlicher, so, und mal gucken, also es gibt in nächster
Zeit noch ein Placement zu Gaming Hardware, kann ich jetzt mal so grob umschreiben, das
kommt in der Mitte des Monats, ja, und den Rest müssen wir mal gucken, easy money, easy
life, wie gesagt, die Gasheizungsrechnung bezahlt sich ja nicht von alleine, als sich
das Haus hier, bzw. das Haus renoviert haben, war es eine gute Idee, eine Gasheizung einzubauen,
heute wäre das keine so gute Idee, auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, Alternativen
so irgendwie mit Heizöl oder Pellets oder so, ist auch teuer als fuck geworden, wäre
wahrscheinlich auch nicht besser gewesen, Hardware Rad Placements, wann, ohne Mist, wir hatten
uns das vor einer Weile mal überlegt, aber ich weiß gar nicht, was da rausgekommen ist,
wir wollten mal irgendwas machen, aber ich glaube, also entweder hat es er vergessen
oder ich vergessen, aber da ist nie, da ist nie großartig was rausgekommen, ich glaube,
du hast beide vergessen, jetzt wo du es sagst, ja, ich hoffe, bei dem läuft es gut, also
sind Leute, denen gönne ich wirklich den Erfolg, ja, und jetzt kann ich was dazu sagen, gerade
auch Stream hat er gerade erst angefangen, jetzt kann ich was dazu sagen, Leute, ich
habe, heute, morgen, habe ich die Mail geschickt, mit Skill-Liste und Lebenslauf und ihr werdet
es nicht glauben, ich habe mit ein paar Stunden Verzögerung was bekommen, das habe ich noch
nie gekriegt, und zwar, Moment, Moment, Moment, ich muss das jetzt ein bisschen anonymisiert
vorlesen, ich habe Folgendes bekommen, herzlich willkommen im Online-Karriereportal, lieber
Max, schön, dass du dir vorstellen kannst, mit uns für uns zu arbeiten, du hast ab sofort
die Möglichkeit, dich in deinem Karriereportal einzuloggen, also sprich, ich kann jetzt online
nachgucken, was meine Bewerbung gerade so macht, was sich alles gibt, ganz davon abgesehen,
ich habe ja eh den Shortcut genommen, was die Bewerbung angeht, ich wurde ja angeschrieben
von einem, der dort Teamleiter ist jetzt, und hat gemeint, Max willst nicht bei uns anfangen,
das heißt, ich musste kein Anschreiben machen, und ich musste auch sonst nichts hier großartig
großartig machen, ich habe Skill-Liste und Lebenslauf hingeschickt und fertig, ja, wahrscheinlich
wird es aktualisiert, wenn es durch ist, Shortcut, bin echt mal gespannt, ja, ich habe die Tabs
noch alle auf, Leute, nicht, dass ihr denkt, ich habe die Tabs zugemacht, also, ich habe
jetzt Chrome aufgemacht für den Chat, weil ich habe das Gefühl, dass es gelaggelt ein
bisschen an Chromium lag, und eventuell wegen den Plugins, die ich laufen hatte, ja, also
so sieht es aus aktuell mit neuem Job, wie gesagt, Bewerbung ist heute raus, und die
gucken jetzt mal, wie das, wir müssen uns ja wie gesagt eh nochmal wegen Teilzeit, Gehalt,
Remote und allem so unterhalten, dass wir uns alle einig sind, und wie gesagt, ich wollte
ja auch mal ein Probe-Anguck-Tag machen, ein Probe, das wird kein richtiger Tag sein, wahrscheinlich
so 2-3 Stunden mal ein bisschen rumgucken, was ist da los, das Ganze natürlich Remote,
und dann wollten sie sich auch mal schlau machen, wann das geht, wie gesagt, das ist
alles noch nicht raus, wie viel Geld, also ich meine, gut, es muss mindestens das sein,
was ich jetzt auch verdiene, aber mit Inflation und allem eher ein bisschen mehr, weil ich
muss da jetzt auch mehr, also ich verlange ja schon mehr, plus die drücken sich immer
noch, aber spätestens Ende des Jahres, und gerade wenn das jetzt ein Remote-Probe, korrekt,
natürlich, was soll ich da vor Ort hinfahren, ich will auch wissen, wie das ist, wie handeln
die das Remote, ich werde rein Remote arbeiten, also will ich doch nicht wissen, wie es vor
Ort ist, wenn ich Remote arbeiten werde, sondern ich will wissen, wie die das mit Remote handeln,
ich meine, dass ich da keinen super krass freigeschaltenen VPN-Zugang bekomme am ersten
Tag, wenn ich noch nicht mal dort unterschrieben habe, das ist schon klar, wahrscheinlich wird
es darauf rauslaufen, dass ich mit einem irgendwie mal 1-2 Stunden Teams-Dings mache, und er zeigt
mir ein bisschen was, und ich kann ein bisschen was fragen, und ja, vielleicht darf ich auch
mal irgendwo meinen Senf zugeben oder so, ist das auch in Frankfurt, nee, ist nicht
in Frankfurt, ist in Wetzlar, ist ein bisschen weiter wie Frankfurt, Wetzlar kenne ich, Wetzlar
war ich schon mal im Ziviliens, wo ich Ziviliens gemacht habe, musste ich da mal hin, da war,
ich glaube, irgendein so ein komischer Kurs, wo ich eingebent bin bei, kann ich mich heute
daran erinnern, ich glaube, da war so ein komischer Kurs, wo man was über den Umgang mit behinderten
Leuten lernt, weil ich habe ja mein, ich habe ja euch ja schon mal erzählt, ich habe ja
mein Ziviliens in einer Behindertenwerkstatt gemacht, und da musste man so einen Kurs machen,
so irgendwie Umgang mit behinderten Leuten, und da haben sie uns irgendwelche Filme gezeigt,
irgendwelche Diskussionsrunden gehabt, Leute, das ging eine Woche lang, das ging eine Woche
lang, ich habe mir den Arm verstaucht, ich bin ohne Scheiß, das Ganze, ich weiß es heute
noch, das Ganze sollte montags losgehen, und das war irgendwie nur einmal im halben Jahr,
man sollte diesen Kurs unbedingt mitmachen, ganz furchtbar wichtig, ja, und Montag, ja,
ja, nicht Sonntag, Montagmorgen, nee, Schwachsinn, nee, doch, Sonntagabend, Sonntagabend, nicht
Montagmorgen, Sonntagabend bin ich aufs Maul gefallen in der Badewanne, und habe mir übelst
den, wie heißt das, keine Ahnung, wie das heißt, den Muskel zwischen Arm, also wenn
ihr den Arm so hoch macht, der Muskel, der quasi, also wenn ihr den Arm so anhebt, sodass
euer Ellenbogen auf Kopfhöhe ist, der Muskel, der so an den Achselhöhlen vorbei dann runter
an der Seite geht, ja, so was quasi vom Arm über geht so in die Seite, den habe ich mir
übelst gezerrt, und es hat wehgetan, es, fuck, und da habe ich dann angerufen und gesagt,
ja, wenn wir das jetzt verschieben müssen und sonst wie, ich, der Arzt hat mich irgendwie
krankgeschrieben für zwei Tage, dann bin ich dann Mittwoch erst hin, hinten oder von
unten, Moment, Moment, Moment, Muskel, Muskelnarm, ja, Moment, nee, nee, nee, innen, innen,
innen, was, was bin ich hier sehend, also, Moment, Moment, es ist, der, Moment, ich kann
es gerade jetzt nicht, äh, der außen, nee, der da, der da, das müsste der hier gewesen
sein, das müsste hier irgendwo neben das gewesen sein, aber, aber, es, es, es war
der Muskel, der hier so lang ging, so richtig, also quasi unterm, unterm Arm so dann zum,
zumindest hat es unterm Arm gezogen, so, keine Ahnung wie das Ding heißt, auch vollkommen
egal, aber es hat wirklich wehgetan, das kann ich heute noch dran erinnern, ich bin wirklich
richtig aufs Maul gepreddert in der Badewanne, beim raussteigen von der Badewanne, ich hab
hier nun Zwischending war das, zwischen hängen bleiben und ausrutschen, ich bin hängen geblieben
beim, das war in der Badewanne, da hatte ich noch keine normale Dusche, aber heute hab
ich ja, heute hab ich so eine ganz normale Dusche, wo man, wo man reingeht, am liebsten
hätte ich ja eine Schnecken-Dusche, kennt, kennt ihr Schnecken-Duschen, richtig, Pog,
leider hat es die Decke von, vom Haus hier nicht ausgehalten, sonst hätt ich eine Schnecken-Dusche
gehabt, Schneck, das hat, das ist nichts unanständiges, also auch wenn jetzt einer denkt irgendwie,
das klingt, nee, nee, das ist eine, meint, Schnecken-Dusche, sowas ist das, das hätt
ich hier gerne gehabt, wo man so rein läuft, richtig nice, sowas, sowas hätt ich hier
gerne gehabt, leider hält die Decke das an der Stelle nicht aus, sonst hätt ich so ein
Ding gehabt.
Das, das finde ich, das, das hätt ich, das hätt ich wirklich gerne gehabt, so ein Teil
hier, jetzt hab ich eine normale Dusche, zumindest in der alten Wohnung, hatte ich halt weder
das noch das, sondern hatte ich eine Badewanne, wo ich vorher gewohnt hab, da hatte ich ganz
normale Badewanne und wenn man in der Badewanne steht und man will aus der Badewanne raus,
dann gibt's halt die Möglichkeit, dass man mit dem Fuß irgendwie beim raussteigen, dann
irgendwie, weiß ich auch nicht, was ich gemacht hab, keine Ahnung, irgendwie hängen bleibt
und dann noch ein bisschen rutscht und dann fällt man auf's Maul, ja, dann fällt man
nach vorne, ja, fällt man nach vorne, ich kann euch das erzählen, und wenn man nach
vorne fällt, dann fängt man sich ja ab, also wenn man sich abfängt, abfängt, ich hab's
irgendwie geschafft, den linken Arm so auf Kopfhöhe zu haben zum Abfang und den rechten
Arm irgendwie nach vorne und dann hab ich halt den Arm ausgestreckt nach vorne gehabt
und hab halt nach unten gedrückt, um mich abzufangen, so und das hat irgendwie dann
dazu gereicht, dass ich das irgendwie gezerrt hab, oder, fragt mich nicht, keine Ahnung,
zumindest war ich sogar im Krankenhaus an dem Tag, ähm, weil die irgendwie erst gedacht
haben, ist vielleicht was abgerissen oder sowas, was da zum Glück nicht der Fall war,
aber es hat weh getan, zumindest lange Rede kurzer Sinn, wo wir gerade dabei waren, genau,
da hab ich Ziviliens gemacht und da musste ich dann nach Wetzlar auf diese Schulung,
da hab ich mit der Frau vom Ziviliens damals telefoniert und die hat gemeint, also wenn
sie da Mittwoch noch hingehen, dann lassen wir es gut sein und sie müssen da nur drei
Tage gehen.
Da hab ich gesagt, okay, alles klar, so schlimm ist der Arm nicht, Keg W, ist nicht so wild,
ich geh dahin, weil, also, sonst müsste ich ja nochmal woanders hin, also, hingegangen
und mir drei Tage diesen komischen, komischen Kurs gegeben, da hat man halt irgendwelche
Diskussionsrunden gemacht, Filme Leute, ich hab halt noch nie so demotiviert, Filme hab
ich gepennt bei, das würd ich heute gar nicht mehr machen ohne Scheiß, das ist übelst
krass, so Disrespect für alle, die da irgendwie in den Kurs liegen lassen, hab ich gepennt
bei dem, ich hab nichts gemacht, ich hab einfach nur da gesessen, hab mir gedacht, alter, lasst
mich wieder heim, so ein Scheiß, weiß ich noch, zumindest bin ich dann nach den drei
Tagen was durch, ja, oh man, ja, ganz ehrlich, also, das Apo Red Genshin Placement war schon
fail, vor allem, weil er gesagt hat, er spielt das selbst, aber ganz im Ernst, wisst ihr,
was ich auch fail finde, ich hab ja nur so eine Sache mitgekriegt, was wir mal kurz
im Video geguckt haben, was ich echt fail finde, das anscheinend sein Cutter privates
Videomaterial an irgendwelche Leute weitergibt und dass die da draus dann ihn quasi fertig
machen können, also, das gehört sich nicht, unabhängig davon, wie CAC W das Placement
ist oder nicht, stimmt schon, das denen letztendlich aber auch egal, hauptsächlich, die haben ihre
Punkte da drinnen, was ist das, die Brückenmap im neuen Cut, ja, tolle Map, tolle Map, tolle
Map, ja, super, jetzt explodiert gleich, hauptsächlich, jetzt explodiert eine Granate, oder, ne, ja,
diese Map ist wirklich Müll, bestes, bestes, im Ort, was wir hier haben.
Ah, danke schön, 40 Monate, Massive Hyper Subscription hier, keine Ahnung, wie man das
40 Monate aushält, vor allem auch noch als Discord Admin und Mod, aber schön, dass ihr
alle am Start seid, schön, dass du auf 40 Monate am Start gewesen bist, Massive Pog,
Mario Kart Double Dash Musik, ja, cringe, was ist denn jetzt schon wieder, cringe, alles
ist cringe heutzutage, sagst du irgendwas cringe, sagst du nix, ist auch cringe, wie
viel Geld, ähm, bezog sich das, Renovin bezog sich das auf das Matchmasters Placement,
auf den Job, ähm, das ist die Frage, wie gesagt, wir haben da noch nicht drüber gesprochen,
aber wie gesagt, es muss mindestens das sein, was ich jetzt verdiene, bloß ein bisschen
mehr, weil Inflation und bei mir muss es eh sich wieder mal was tun, ist alles teurer geworden
und ich sehs nicht ein da, ich wollt grad sagen von Appel und Ei zu arbeiten ist ja nicht
so, aber ich sehs nicht ein, dass im Vergleich mit drumherum, dass es weniger ist, ja, Traum
vor der Hauptbahnhof ist Z-Gear, ja, aber richtig Z-Gear, nächstes Jahr auf der Gamescom,
ja, wie gesagt, ich hab mein Zivilist gemacht, einer Behindertenwerkstatt und ich muss ehrlich
sagen, Leute, das war wirklich, also ihr wisst, ich hasse jegliche Menschen, ist mir egal,
ob weiß, ob schwarz, ob Asiate, ob Behinderte oder nicht, ich mag keine Menschen, aber,
eins muss ich sagen, das war für mich eine besonders große Herausforderung am Anfang,
überhaupt mich dazu zu überwinden, mit den Leuten irgendwie zu interagieren, weil, das
ist so eine Zwisch, das ist so eine Mischung aus Kindergarten und betreutem Wohnen, irgendwie
so eine Behindertenwerkstatt, aber ich muss sagen, es war tatsächlich im Nachhinein betrachtet
eines der so einprägsamsten Dinger, die ich je gemacht hab, ist wirklich so, also ich würde
das im Leben für kein Geld der Welt hauptberuflich machen wollen, aber so dieses Dreivierteljahr
oder so, was das ungefähr war, war wirklich nicht verkehrt es gemacht zu haben, was ich
da zum Beispiel gelernt hab, ist in meiner Zeit in der Behindertenwerkstatt, dass so ziemlich
jeder mehr Lobby in Deutschland hat, wie die, dort fehlt es an Geld, da fehlt es im Prinzip
an allem, man könnte jetzt sagen, das ist bei vielen Stellen so, aber da ist es wirklich
extrem, das Gebäude ist kaputt und die Leute flicken das teilweise in ihrer Freizeit, die
Gruppen sind viel zu groß für die 1-2 Leute, die da drin rum sitzen, zumal, du dort ja
auch Leute hast, die kompletten theoretischen Ganztagsbetreuung auch bräuchten, nicht dass
zu trotz muss man sagen, die Leute selbst dort, am Anfang denkt man so, ihr seid alle gleich,
ihr habt alle einen an der Waffe, was soll ich mit euch anfangen, aber wenn man ne Weile
da ist, merkt man, dass die alle unterschiedlich, wie soll man sagen, dass die alle unterschiedlich
einen an der Waffe haben, ich mein, so wie wir auch, also es sind alles individuell unterschiedliche
Leute, die auch unterschiedliche Macken, also unterschiedliche Ticks haben, die eine wollte
immer beispielsweise auf dem Stuhl schaukeln, der andere ist regelmäßig, Leute, auch wenn
ich ein bisschen abschweife, aber das muss ich euch mal erzählen, das fand ich damals
lustig, hab ich mich noch monatelang drüber kaputt gelacht, ich hab da ein echt aus der
Fassung gebracht, und zwar, also einer von den Behinderten in der Behindertenwerkstatt,
ich habe zweimal am Tag mich in Kiosk gesetzt dort, da gab es so einen großen Mittagsessraum
und so ein Kiosk, da konnten die Leute dann beispielsweise Fanta kaufen oder Snickers
kaufen, das war so ein kleiner Kiosk, im Prinzip konnten die Leute da mit ihrem Taschengeld
sich ein bisschen Naschen kaufen, auf gut Deutsch, das war halt so aufgezogen, wie die
jetzt in den echten Laden gehen und so, das hat denen natürlich auch ein bisschen Selbstsicherheit
gegeben, ich geh jetzt einkaufen und so, zumindest hab ich da im Kiosk gesessen, zweimal am Tag
und hab den Behinderten dort halt Zeug verkauft, musste er jemanden machen, der halbwegs rechnen
kann, ich war nicht der krasseste, bin nicht Quickmuffs, aber im zweistelligen Bereich
kann ich noch rechnen, dass das ja auch ungefähr stimmt, so, und da kam jeden Tag einer, also
ich hab das übrigens auch gerne gemacht in Kiosk gesetzt, da musste ich sonst nichts
machen und ich konnte im Kiosk immer ein bisschen was selbst fressen, oder ich hab es richtig
zugenommen in der Zeit, zumindest da kam jeden Tag immer einer und meinte, Max, Max, ich
sag Reiner, was ist denn, Reiner hieß er, weiß noch, Reiner, Max, Max, Reiner, was gibt's?
Und dann meinte er so, darf ich gucken, darf ich gucken, also das heißt auf nicht hessisch
so viel, darf ich mich hier hinstellen und zugucken, ja, darf ich zugucken, da ist er
immer angekommen jeden Tag, Max, Max, darf ich gucken, darf ich gucken und jedes Mal hab
ich zu ihm gesagt, Reiner, du kannst jetzt hier nicht stehen bleiben und gucken, guck
mal, hier sind so viele Leute, ich hab's immer versucht zu erklären, dass er nicht da stehen
bleiben kann und gucken, er hat es ja letztendlich einzig und allein gemacht, um Aufmerksamkeit
zu erlangen, ja, weil er wusste, die Leute setzen sich da mit ihm auseinander und man
muss ihm antworten, er kann ein bisschen Blödsinn erzählen, so, und eines Tages hab ich ihn
echt geschockt, da kam er wieder an, Max, darf ich gucken, darf ich gucken, gesagt, klar
Reiner, darfst immer gucken, dann hat er mich angeguckt, der wusste gar nicht, was er sagen
sollte, hat er da gestanden, der hat wirklich exakt so da gestanden, genau so und er hat
ohne Scheiß 5 Minuten nichts gesagt, aber ich hab ihm in seinem Gesicht angesehen 5
Minuten lang, er hat übertrieben gedacht, also sein komplettes Gehirn musste neue Synapsen
bilden, weil diese Antwort, das war krass, der hat da gestanden, so, fuck, Alter, was
mach ich denn jetzt, ich darf jetzt gucken, jetzt kann ich mit dem ja gar nicht diskutieren
und wisst ihr, was er nach 5 Minuten gemacht hat, nach 5 Minuten hat er gesagt, Max, ist
ja ganz schön langweilig hier, ich geh wieder, und dann war er weg, da hab ich den Dach
nochmal gesehen, weißt du, vorher musste ich mit dem immer ewig diskutieren, dass er jetzt
weggeht und da stand er halt einfach rum, das sind so die kleinen Sachen, da freut man
sich dann da drüber, der war wirklich komplett fertig dann, ja am Nachmittag dann ist er
wieder nackig unten durchs Erdgeschoss gerannt, das hat er auch gerne gemacht, kann ich mir
noch dran erinnern, der hat sich dann teilweise einfach seine Hose ausgezogen, ist nackig
da durch das Gebäude gerannt und warum, naja, um Aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen und da mussten
sie ihn immer einfangen und mit ihm aufs Klo gehen und sagen, Reiner, jetzt zieh dir mal
wieder die Hose an, oh man, das war tatsächlich ohne Scheiß, ich hatte wahnsinnige Berührungsängste
am Anfang, kann ich euch ehrlich sagen, ich mein, ganz im Herzen, ich glaub die meisten
hätten das wahrscheinlich, ich hab's schon nicht im Umgang mit normalen Leuten und im
Umgang mit behinderten Leuten dementsprechend noch weniger, zumindest dachte ich das eigentlich,
ich bin am Endeffekt mit denen besser klar gekommen als mit normalen Leuten, was ist
eigentlich normal, ich mein, wir haben alle einen Dachschaden, mehr oder weniger, bei
manchen merkst du es mehr, bei manchen merkst du es weniger, bei manchen merkst du es nach
außen hin, manche machen das eher so für sich, aber ich bin wirklich mit den Leuten
dort fast besser klar gekommen als mit den einfachen normalen Leuten, vor allem man hat
mit der Zeit auch so irgendwie so rausgekriegt, was die alles für unterschiedliche Ticks
haben, ja, der eine beispielsweise, der war ultra nervös, mit dem bin ich dann morgens
teilweise, es gab ein paar, die waren mega nervös, sind immer rumgelaufen, haben alle
anderen Leute genervt, mit denen sind wir dann einfach morgens mal eine halbe Stunde
bis Stunde unten in die Turnhalle gegangen, hat ja sonst außer den zivilisten Leuten
keine Zeit, keiner für Zeit gehabt, sind wir mit denen in die Turnhalle gegangen und
man muss dann gar nicht probieren dort irgendwie was zu spielen mit denen, ja, du kannst da
kein, kein was weiß ich, Fußball, Völkerball, sonst was man so spielt, kannste knenken,
du musstest im Prinzip einfach nur das Tor aufmachen, ein paar Bälle in die Mitte der
Turnhalle rollen und die einfach mal eine halbe Stunde rumflitzen lassen, das hat voll
und ganz ausgereicht, du musstest nichts machen, du musst dich dabei setzen, gucken, dass sie
sich nicht kloppen und dann sind die da eine halbe Stunde rumgeflitzt oder eine Stunde
rumgeflitzt und die waren den kompletten Tag über danach ruhig und sonst hatten die immer
richtige Probleme diese Leute unter Kontrolle zu behalten, weil die sind halt den ganzen
Tag unausgelastet da rumgeflitzt und haben andere Leute genervt, also ich muss echt sagen,
das war was, im Nachhinein war das wirklich gut, dass ich das gemacht habe, nicht dass
zu trotz würde ich im Leben nicht sowas beruflich machen wollen, also für kein Geld der Welt
würde ich sowas beruflich machen wollen, also soziale Sachen auf gar keinen Fall, aber
die Zivilienzeit, das hat sich tatsächlich gelohnt, das zu machen, wirklich, mein Chef
Zedge, das werde ich dann sehen, also wenn das jetzt klappt, also mein Chef weiß das,
dem habe ich ja gesagt, ich bewerbe mich woanders und ich habe ihm auch schon gesagt, dass ich
mir was anderes angeguckt habe, also der weiß das, der das Stream hängt, was jetzt, oder
hängt das Stream? Das ist Vodafone, oder? Naja, wenn du antwortest, muss das Stream ja
bei dir gehen, Twitch, meine Stream Vorschau ist kaputt, jetzt gehts hier, meine Stream
Vorschau ist kaputt, warum ist meine Stream Vorschau kaputt? Oh ne, jetzt gehts wieder,
alles gut, jetzt gehts wieder, ok, nice, GG Eats, ne, es war auf jeden Fall wirklich
weg, ich habe es in meiner eigenen Vorschau gesehen, ok, keine Ahnung, wo ich jetzt gerade
stehen geblieben bin, aber, also Chef Zedge, also wie gesagt, der weiß das, dass ich mich
woanders bewerbe und sobald das spruchreif ist, wir uns da einig sind und ich wirklich
dann auch die Absicht habe hinzugehen, da werde ich das nehmen und halt sagen, ey, entweder
können wir uns irgendwie drauf einigen, dass auf Remote, bzw. auch auf mal Perspektive,
was Geld angeht, oder ich gehe woanders hin und reiche meine Kündigung ein zum Ende
des Jahres, er kann ja auch nicht direkt sagen, ja machen wir, der muss das dann erstmal weiter
geben und was auch immer, selbstentscheiden können die ja bei uns nix, aber insofern,
was soll er machen? Und wenn sie nicht wollen, dann bin ich halt weg, ich mein ich kanns
ja auch nicht ändern, man kann sich ja schlecht zu ihrem Glück zwingen oder mich, das ist
ja letztendlich immer noch auf freiwilliger Basis, wenn sie nicht wollen und denken sie
kriegen easy neue Leute, ey, was soll ich machen, ich würde prinzipiell den Leuten
wegen gerne schon da bleiben, allerdings auf der anderen Seite auch wiederum nicht,
allerdings also nicht wegen den Leuten, sondern weil mir halt auch sonst einiges an der Firma
offen Keks geht, also eigentlich ist es mir egal, wenn es ein gutes Angebot gibt, würde
ich sagen, stehen die Chancen gut, dass ich da bleibe, wenn es keins gibt und das andere
mich überzeugt, bin ich halt Ende des Jahres weg, ne im Januar wird da nix diskutiert,
das werde ich nicht machen, ne, ne, ne, das muss schon gleich geklärt sein, ne, das machen
wir nicht, das muss auch schriftlich dann soweit bestätigt sein, denn selbst wenn sie
mir sagen, das gibt es dann, die Vertragsanpassungen gibt es dann erst zum 1. Januar, meinetwegen,
aber das Ding muss unterschrieben sein und es muss vorallem, sonst bin ich weg Ende
des Jahres, das sehe ich da nicht ein, Max bleibst für 3 Monate, wie jetzt, achso du
meinst Kündigungstechnisch, naja, muss ich ja, es sei denn, wir können uns darauf einigen,
dass wir das irgendwie aufheben, wenn man sich dafür entscheidet abzuhören, wäre mir
das persönlich dann sogar schon am liebsten, dann kann ich nämlich schneller bei den anderen
anfangen, hat ja keinen Sinn, dass da irgendwie noch 3 Monate hinzuziehen für nix und wieder
nix, aber mal gucken, da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt, also sie haben ja die Möglichkeit
da ein ordentliches Angebot zu machen. Was ist daran besser als einfach eine bodengleiche
Dusche? Na man kann einfach reinlaufen, man muss keine Tür zumachen oder keinen Vorhang
zumachen und ich finde es einfach so dieses Schwimmbad-Feeling mit gekachelten Wänden
und mit diesen Steinwänden und so finde ich angenehmer, ja, bei so einer Schnecken-Dusche
bei so einem Teil, ich finde das angenehmer, ich habe es ja schon mal ausprobiert, ich
wollte mir eigentlich sowas kaufen, aber gab es halt nicht, weil Decke zu schwach bei
mir hier im Bad, unterm Bad. Beste News von heute? Was gibt's denn? Oh, Initial Gap Support
ist Merged! MonkaS! Haben sie es endlich geschafft! Vielleicht brauche ich dann bald kein E3 Gaps
Fork mehr, die haben sich ja jahrelang dagegen gewehrt. Das ist kein nutzloses Feature, du
siehst viel besser die Abgrenzung zwischen den Fenstern. Was nutzlos ist, vielleicht
sind Gaps außenrum, aber zwischen den Fenstern finde ich Gaps tatsächlich besser um zu sehen,
klar wo welches Fenster, also wer wo wie was zu welcher Anwendung gehört, gerade wenn du
nur zwei Terminal Side-by-Side offen hast, finde ich das ganz praktisch. Shadow Operation,
das ist noch nicht raus, das ist noch nicht raus, ich habe heute den Lebenslauf und die
Skill-Liste an den neuen geschickt, ich habe auch prompt eine Antwort gekriegt, so dass
es jetzt eingegangen ist, letztendlich weiß ich, dass es eingegangen ist, weil ich hab
es an den geschickt, der mich eigentlich auch angeschrieben hat, ob ich nicht bei ihnen
anfangen will. Und ich muss mir das jetzt angucken, also ich habe ja mit denen noch nicht
gesprochen, wir müssen uns erstmal einig sein, was Remote angeht, Arbeitstage angeht und
vor allem Gehalt natürlich angeht. Und dann will ich mir das Ganze mal kurz angucken.
Also ich will mal einen Probetag oder sowas machen, wenn man sich dann einig ist, dann
werde ich sagen, ich habe was Neues und mal gucken, was dann mein aktueller Arbeitgeber
dazu sagt und wenn die es da wieder nicht auf die Reihe kriegen und mich vertrösten
wollen im Zweifelsfall, ja wir gucken dann nächstes Jahr, dann bin ich halt weg. Wie
gesagt, man kann weder mich noch die zu ihrem Glück zwingen, wenn sie nicht wollen, wollen
sie nicht, aber das muss ich auch nicht wollen. Okay, das verstehe ich, ja das verstehe ich,
wenn du nicht bezahlt wirst, ja, das kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen. Erinnert sich
auf einer, wo du sagst, der hat viele illegale Dinge getrieben, ich kann mich, weiß ich nicht,
ich verfolge aboret nicht, ich kann mich noch an den Bomben-Prank erinnern, das war so eines
der, ja, low IQigsten Aktionen, die ich auf YouTube je gesehen habe. Obix, Dankeschön
für den Sub, Silbersubscription hier, Massive. Du bekommst ab Januar 500 Euro mehr im Monat,
ja ich bekomme theoretisch, also zumindest laut Tarifvertrag bekomme ich auch ein bisschen
mehr, vielleicht kommt das sogar Ende des Jahres schon, aber das ist alles nicht der
Rede wert, die müssen schon ordentlich mal ein bisschen was draufpacken, dass sich das
wieder lohnt. Korrekt, mein Zivilin zwar als es noch Wehrpflicht gab, jetzt gibt es
es ja gar nicht mehr, jetzt haben die noch weniger, ja. Kam in den nächsten, ja, ja,
kam regelmäßig zum gucken. Was auch lustig war, ja, ich weiß nicht wie sie hieß, ist
auch wurscht, wo ich da im Kiosk gesessen habe, kam jeden Tag immer eine vorbei, die
wollte Mars haben, also diesen Schokoriegel und die konnte Mars nicht aussprechen, also
ich meine, man muss ja nicht sagen Mars, man muss es ja nicht super aus, super deutlich
aussprechen, die konnte Mars nicht richtig aussprechen, die hat immer gesagt Mars, Mars,
aber ich wusste, ich wusste ja was sie meint und an einem Tag gab es kein Mars mehr, da
kam sie wieder an und meinte Mars, ich dachte es gibt kein Mars, willst du vielleicht was
anderes haben, hier Snickers, Lion, Bounty, Mars, es gibt kein Mars, Mars, wir haben kein
Mars, guck mal, da habe ich ihr die Sachen hingelegt, guck mal, die drei Sachen, was
hältst du denn davon, was hältst du denn davon und das war das erste und einzige Mal,
dass ich ein anderes Wort von der gehört habe, die hat dann gesagt, nach zwei Minuten
überlegen Snickers, ich habe nie wieder ein anderes Wort, davor nicht und danach nicht,
wir hatten ja danach immer wieder Mars, ich habe noch nie ein anderes Wort von der gehört
außer Mars und jetzt einmalig dann Snickers, sie kann tatsächlich was, die versteht was
man sagt und die kann auch wenn sie will, aber Snickers kotze dann, ich habe auch noch
nie Mars mit R gesagt, also nie Mars sowas, ist Mars nicht der römische God of War, Moment,
wir müssen jetzt allgemeinbildungs FPS machen, ja hier, Massify IQ haben wir wieder, Chat,
das weiß ich nur dank den ganzen Prime Subs, ohne die Prime Subs wäre ich viel zu 3 Head,
um sowas zu essen, ok FFF, das ist, äh heute würdest du Verdienst machen, ne ich würde
kein Verdienst machen, ok Umfrage vorgeschlagen, Kekkel, ah das ist wegen dem Komma, ich wollte
gerade sagen, wo ist Kekkel hin, ähm Kekkel, Kek-W oder Kek-U, ok weil du es bist, toll,
ist das so ziemlich die unsinnigste Umfrage die man machen kann, aber ok, ihr könnt abstimmen,
die wichtigsten Fragen auf Twitch müssen geklärt werden, ok zusätzliche Abstimmungen
zulassen mit extra Keksen natürlich, was sonst, den Kram müssen wir mal ein bisschen
loswerden, alles klar, wie ist eigentlich der Name auf YouTube und Twitch entstanden,
sag ich gleich was dazu wenn ich im Chat soweit bin, hab ich nicht vorher auch gesagt, ich
wollte noch was zu irgendwas sagen, ach zum Sellout, das hab ich ja schon erzählt, äh
der Name auf YouTube ist entstanden, weil ich damals, also Max FPS und mit der 4, also
vollermaßen ist das gewesen, ich hab damals gerne FPS Russia geguckt, falls das noch irgendjemand
kennt, aber ich gehe davon aus, der war ja sehr bekannt, damals hat er aber hauptsächlich
noch Call of Duty Videos gemacht, FPS Russia again, Kekomrits, genau und deswegen dachte
ich mir FPS ist schon mal gut und ich mach ja hauptsächlich Shooter und sowas, ja und
Max, weil ich Max heiß, ist auch irgendwie klar und das 4, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
Max ist zu blöd, aber für LeadSpeak klingt das nicht schlecht, Perloma Friends, ok nice,
das hat gewonnen, Kekkel, sehr gut, finde ich genau die richtige Reihenfolge, Kekkel
und KekW ist ungefähr gleich auf, wobei ich persönlich Kekkel den Vorzug geben würde,
KekQ ist Nision Emote, kann man ab und zu mal verwenden, aber meistens reicht Kekkel
oder KekW, natürlich muss man sagen, für alle Lowbrates sieht schon ein bisschen so
aus oder, aber nach wie vor ist 0W immer noch das beste Lachemote, auch wenn KekW mittlerweile
0 ziemlich verdrängt hat, aber ich muss sagen 0W immer noch das beste Lachemote, dazu muss
jemand an dieses Video denken, 0W vs. KekW, pass mal auf das Intro, Moment, Moment, weiss
ich ob man es überhaupt gehört hat wegen der Musik, können wir den Kekonersong hören,
du meinst hier, KekConer, ja den hören wir nachher den Kekonersong, den hören wir uns
die Sache an und danach hören wir uns den Mega Upload Song an, KekConer, Twitch Emotes,
die Amis haben geklortes Leitungswasser, wirklich warum haben die denn sowas, das kann man ja
gar nicht trinken, kann man Amis kein Leitungswasser trinken, geht das nicht, nee, ok, keine Ahnung
ich war da noch nicht, was nicht, ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich hab da keinerlei Hang,
dahin zu gehen, ja Sway kann ich leider nicht, Wayland kann ich leider, dementsprechend Sway
kann ich nicht gescheit benutzen bei mir, weil ich hab das ganze in der VM laufen und
in der VM funktioniert Wayland nicht richtig und ja das ist ein Wayland Bug, der ist auch
bekannt aber interessiert keinen, Wayland in VM kannst du klicken leider, der hat noch
nicht mal den Screen refreshed bei mir ohne irgendwelche Hacks, hast du Outlast Trials
Demo gespielt, was, Outlast Trials, ach das ist doch, ist das nicht dieses Horror, Horror
Game, gibt es jetzt wieder was neues, nee ist nicht mein Genre, kann sich noch einer
an Outcast das Game erinnern, so 1996 oder so, 1999, ja, kennt das noch jemand, das war
mega die Grafik damals, also Environment Grafik, die Grafik an sich war ziemlich kacke, weil
du damals auch schon so Games wie Unreal hattest, was Polygon Pixel Umgebung und so was war,
aber die Landschaft alles, das war wirklich wirklich mega mega nice damals, alles andere
sah in dem Game halt kacke aus, aber die Umgebung sah wirklich wirklich nice aus für die damalige
Zeit, ich finde das Wasser sieht doch immer noch gut aus und man konnte ja das Game später
mit besseren PC's und so auch auf höhere Auflösung spielen, das hat lange Zeit auch
aktuellere PC's ziemlich ziemlich ins Schwitzen gebracht, ja, sag mal, oh je, jetzt machen
wir aber ein Fass auf hier, sag mal welche Vorzüge, die du bei entweder iOS oder Android
siehst, finde ich mittlerweile extrem gut geworden, es ist beides ziemlich gut, also
ich, nehmen wir mal, machen wir es mal nicht zu ausführlich, ja, nehmen wir mal wirklich
so für mich so die wichtigsten Punkte, also, iOS ist für mich finde ich das perfekte System,
was du deiner Mutter oder deiner Oma oder so geben kannst, die damit nichts großartig
machen will, außer es einfach irgendwie benutzen, Android ist ein System, also meiner Ansicht
hat es besseres System für Leute, die sich damit auseinandersetzen wollen und vor allem,
die da dran auch was automatisieren wollen oder da dran auch was machen wollen, was jetzt
vielleicht nicht auf drei vorgefertigte Buttons passt, sowas wie Tasker zum Beispiel, ist
unter iOS nicht möglich, nicht denkbar, natürlich gibt es mittlerweile sowas wie Shortcuts,
aber Shortcuts und Tasker da liegen Welten dazwischen, Shortcuts ist absolut Pille-Palle
versus Tasker und es müsste nicht mal Tasker sein, unter Android kannst du dir auch komplette
Linux Umgebung installieren, die du damit Tasker integrierst, du kannst quasi dann Tasker
Bash Scripts aufrufen oder Python Scripts aufrufen und was auch immer, also wenn es
ums Thema Individualisierung, vor allem Automatisierung geht, ist Android das beste was es gibt, da
kackt iOS komplett dagegen ab, fürs tägliche Benutzen oder eben für die Mutter oder für
die Oma und für den Opa oder was auch immer, ist iOS finde ich besser, also so die reine
wie soll man sagen Out of Box, Usability, App Qualität, muss ich persönlich auch sagen
kommt mir im iOS App Store besser vor und sagen wir mal das was da ist gut umgesetzt
zu haben, das finde ich unter iOS besser, deswegen verwende ich auch quasi täglich
ein iPad und ein iPhone, wobei ich das iPhone hauptsächlich verwende, weil ich umsonst
bekomme, deswegen verwende ich auch hauptsächlich iOS, aber für alles andere, wie beispielsweise
meine Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboards und solche Geschichten, das ist alles Android,
weil das wäre gar nicht möglich mit iOS und das sieht man wieder daran, man muss
halt einfach gucken, dass man das System nimmt, das ist übrigens bei Linux und Windows und
Playstation, Xbox und Intel, AMD was auch immer, das ist alles das gleiche, es hat
keinen Sinn eine Seite unsinnig zu fanboyen und quasi alles damit machen zu wollen nur
weil man irgendwie krasser Fanboy ist, sondern man muss das nehmen was für den jeweiligen
Anwendungszweck am besten ist, für mich ist es so für die tägliche Benutzung finde
ich iOS recht nice und für Automatisierungs-Sachen da scheißt iOS komplett, ab dagegen dann
nehme ich Android und so kann ich das beste nehmen für das was ich machen will ohne mich
um irgendwelche Fanboy Krieggedanken zu machen.
Wayland funktioniert mit GPU Pass-Through, das ist mir vollkommen wurscht, ich kann
kein GPU Pass-Through machen, hier mit Vmware Workstation und ich kann auch kein QEMO verwenden
gescheit und aber gut theoretisch schon, aber du meinst ja QEMO KVM und das bringt mir
auch nichts.
Ich habe Windows als Hostsystem und das muss auch so bleiben für Gaming und Videokram
und Thumbnailerstellung und alles mögliche, ich glaube das passt am besten zusammen.
Ich lade gerade wieder Battlefield 2042 und langweilig, oh das stimmt schon, also kaufen
würde ich es keinem empfehlen wirklich nicht, es sei denn ihr bekommt das am Weihnachten
wieder im Sale für ein paar Euro dann kann man das machen.
Weiß nicht mehr was du meinst, das ist zu lang her, guck mal ich bin wieder 20 Minuten
hinten dran.
Sagt der Schweizer der noch eine ganze Ecke mehr verdient, mal ganz davon abgesehen ja
ich kann mich nicht beklagen bzw. im Durchschnitt ja verdiene ich sicherlich nicht schlecht,
aber ich sehe es auch nicht ein mehr zu verdienen als was sagen wir mal so in dem Umfeld üblich
ist, nur weil es mein Arbeitgeber nicht auf die Reihe bekommt und sich immer selbst feiert
jedes Jahr, aber der Meinung ist ja selbst feiern reicht schon als Gehalt so nach dem
Motto wir sind so ein geiler Laden, wir brauchen nicht mehr Geld bezahlen wir müssen uns einfach
nur genug abfeiern.
Und wer von euch, jetzt mal ernsthaft Hand aufs Herz mal, wer von euch würde zu einer
Gehaltserhöhung nein sagen, stell euch mal vor der Chef kommt zu euch und sagt ihr kriegt
mehr Geld, würde irgendjemand ne sagen, also wenn ihr die Chance habt mehr zu bekommen
würde keiner nein sagen, warum auch, Grafikkarte Gebrauch kaufen ja oder nein ich bin kein
Fan von Gebrauch Grafikkarten weil da weißt du nie was die Leute vorher mit veranstaltet
haben vor allem ist das dann meistens von privat und dementsprechend kriegst du das
Ding machst rein irgendwelche Pixelfehler und dann sagt der Typ dir dann ah die gab
es aber bei mir noch nicht oder halt irgendwelche Bildfehler weil der Grafikkartenramen irgendein
Schlagwerk hat und dann sagt er oh ich hatte aber keine Pixelfehler muss an deinem Rechner
liegen ne ne ne da kriegst du kein Geld wieder da hast du Probleme ich würde keine Grafikkarte
gekauft Gebrauch kaufen. Zodiac1995 Dankeschön für den Sub, Prime Subscription hier, Massive
Subs. Ja also Name auf YouTube habe ich erklärt Name auf Twitch ist ganz einfach entstanden
Name auf Twitch ich musste irgendwas eingeben was noch nicht belegt war für einen privaten
Twitch Account den Max FPS Twitch Account den hab ich den besitze ich übrigens ja den
gibt es den habe ich registriert 2014 oder so aber den wollte ich ja nie benutzen ursprünglich
und ich hab mir nen Account erstellt um privat Twitch zu gucken nämlich den Wubblors Account
und irgendwann dachte ich mir so ich fang an zu streamen und hab dann den Wubblors Account
genommen und nachdem ich das ein bisschen gemacht hab eigentlich ist es ganz nice weil
es gibt auf YouTube schon viele Deppen und die finden mich da nicht so leicht um mich
hier zu nerven das heißt die Leute die hier her kommen das sind die high IQ Leute die
ich hier haben will dementsprechend ist es halt Wubblors geblieben ja
der Kokona Song alles klar ich hab's ja gesagt wir lassen jetzt mal den Kokona Song nebenbei
laufen Moment ist zu leise was ist hier los warum ist es so leise Kekona what the fuck
Moment Windows Mixer jetzt aber
Kokona
Twitch Chat hell yeah
Kappa PogChamp
This Game
Kappa PogChamp, PeopleForehead, BibleThumb, TwitchyMoles, still here is Borg in the morning
and now he calls me, this doggy emote reminds me of a time far away, looking at a chat I get a feeling that I missed emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
TwitchyMoles, from long ago, made you feel you're not alone, Pog is PogChamp, Kappa is Kappa, BibleThumb, TwitchyMoles, Pepehands.
TwitchyMoles, BibleThumb, TwitchyMoles.
Hatshots, das erreicht keiner realistisch und dann packen wir es auf Level 100 vom Battle Pass,
sodass die Leute, die nur Medium viel spielen, schön rein cashen am Ende des Monats noch für
Maximum Battle Pass Level, dass wir noch ein paar Euro kriegen sollen. Das sind dann die Überlegungen,
die finde ich natürlich kacke, wenn quasi Sachen im Spiel künstlich verschlechtert werden bei
Vollpreisspielen, um auf andere Art und Weise mehr Geld rein zu holen. Also ist immer in der Frage,
wie es gemacht wird und die Zeiten, dass das verlangt wird, was ein Entwickler bzw.
Spielehersteller selbst für angemessen halten ist vorbei, gab es ja letztens diese,
was waren das, ehemalige Blizzard-Mitarbeiter, die sich darüber ausgelassen haben über den Wechsel
bzw. über den Merch damals mit, was waren die, Vivendi waren die glaube ich damals Blizzard,
also dass da quasi Blizzard und Activision zu Activision, Blizzard gemercht ist damals,
die darüber berichtet haben, dass sie eigentlich World of Warcraft und sonstige Shop-Items wollten
sie anbieten für 2-3 Euro, so dass was sie quasi der Meinung waren, was diese Items wirklich wert
sind bzw. das was sie für angemessen halten, wirklich wert ist immer so eine Frage bei so
Online-Spielen und dann hat Activision gesagt, was, 3, 2 Euro für neues Cosmetik, ne ne ne Blizzard,
das geht nicht, das muss 15 Euro kosten. Und ich kann mich noch damals dran erinnern,
ich hab damals, entweder hab ich damals ein Video zu gemacht oder ich glaube das war schon
mehr oder weniger ja durch, ich hab auf jeden Fall in einem Video ein längeres Segment mal drinnen
gehabt, wo ich mich da drüber geäußert habe, über das, was bei Activision Blizzard damals befürchtet,
was ich befürchtet hab, also sprich, dass immer mal BWL Leute quasi mitreden wollen, was Games angeht
und da haben die Leute damals in den Kommentaren gesagt, Max, du siehst das alles viel zu, viel zu
noobisch, also du hast ja von BWL und Sachen keine Ahnung, der hätte dich jetzt natürlich
kontern können und sagen, ich hab ein halbes Jahr eine BWL Ausbildung gemacht, ne, die hat gesagt,
du bist ja Kacknoob was BWL angeht, das ist jetzt ja nicht so, als wäre Blizzard, also haben die
wortwörtlich fast Quote, hab ich heute noch im Kopf unter dem Video geschrieben, es wäre jetzt
ja nicht so, als wäre Blizzard jetzt irgendwie bei Activision angestellt, die können nach wie
vor machen, was sie wollen, da hab ich damals gesagt, okay, ich kann das auf BWL-Ebene nicht
argumentieren, aber ich bin mir sicher, das hat Einfluss drauf und über lange Zeit, spätestens
über längere Zeit die nächsten paar Jahre werden wir sehen, dass immer mehr Activision-Praktiken
bei Blizzard einzugehalten und ich hatte letztendlich Recht, dass es so ist, was auch sonst, was hätte
sonst rauskommen sollen, klar, die Leute mussten mich damals wieder belehren, kann überhaupt nicht
sein und ich konnte das BWL-technisch nicht erklären, weil ich hab von BWL-Geschichten keine Ahnung,
auch wenn ich meine Ausbildung teilweise da drin gemacht hab, aber es ist so gekommen,
wie es kommen musste und das haben die jetzt eben auch berichtet, dass es damals so war,
dass man gesagt hat, nee, nee, nee, nicht zwei, drei Euro für irgendwie eine Microtransaction,
Kosmetik, sondern klein 15 Euro, also ja, das ist meine Meinung zu Battle Passes,
auf der einen Seite gut, auf der anderen Seite schlecht, wir werden es auf jeden Fall nicht
mal loswerden und wenn, dann heißt es einfach nicht mal Battle Pass, sondern irgendwie anders,
das evolft ja auch alles, das entwickelt sich ja auch weiter und vielleicht haben wir in ein paar
Jahren was ganz anderes, aber bestimmt nichts besseres, also nichts, dass es für uns günstiger
wird oder besser wird in der Qualität, es wird eher noch undurchsichtiger, sodass wir eben noch
schlechter merken, wann uns das Geld an welcher Stelle aus der Tasche gezogen wird, also gut und
schlecht zugleich, kann man, kann das schlecht sagen, ob es jetzt, ob man das jetzt positiv
negativ findet, es hat beide, hat von beiden Seiten was, ja siehste und wozu soll ich da Linux
verwenden als Hauptsystem, wenn manche sagen, ich funktioniere, das ist halt das Ding, ja man kann
das machen und ich verstehe auch und ich habe damit auch keine Schmerzen mit, wenn das manche Leute so
machen, aber für mich macht es keinen Sinn, also wenn du sagst, du willst eigentlich kein Windows,
du willst nur ab und zu mal, machst dualboot, ey soll jeder machen, was er will, ich für meine,
für meinen Workflow ist es ziemlich unsinnig, Linux als Main System zu verwenden, ich verwende
Linux, so ziemlich alles an Technik, was ich machen will und Gaming und Videoproduktion läuft
unter Windows, fertig, so habe ich das Beste aus beiden Welten, ich muss nicht dualbooten, was mich
übelst abfacken würde und es funktioniert einfach und das ist ja das worauf es letztendlich ankommt,
der Kram muss funktionieren und er muss irgendwie handelbar sein, warum gibt es hier kein Two-Head,
wir haben nur Three-Head zu bieten, mittlerweile sind die Leute hier alle so high IQ, Two-Head ist
outdated, brauchen wir nicht, weil ihr wisst ja, durch jeden Prime-Sub geht der Intelligenzquotient des Chats
durch die Decke, so quasi Schwarmintelligenz, also wir sind aus Two-Head sind wir raus, das geringste
was wir hier können ist Three-Head, normal ist er mittlerweile ja schon Five-Head-Modus,
deswegen machen wir beim Programmieren auch so und sowas auch nie Fehler, ja ok das habe ich
vorhin falsch ausgedrückt, wenn du sagst ich will mehr Geld, dann der Chef sagt ja, wer würde dann sagen
ne doch nicht, so habe ich das gemeint, so niemand würde mehr Geld erst mal ablehnen,
ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer, da müsste man mal Algorithmen verstehen fragen, der nicht mal
Algorithmen verstehen heißt, der wüsste das, ich habe mir eh überlegt, ich habe ihn noch nicht
gefragt, eigentlich müsste ich mir mal ein Stream machen, der hat mir erzählt, weiß gar nicht ob ich
das erzählen darf, aber ich glaube das hat er auch schon bei sich auf YouTube erzählt, dass er in
Zukunft ein bisschen Streams machen will, wahrscheinlich will er es aber auf YouTube machen,
ich habe mir schon überlegt ob ich ihn mal fragen soll, ob wir nicht mal zusammen ein Stream machen
und ein paar so Ausbildungsstudiums und FAQ Sachen machen sollen, gerade dann können bei mir im
Stream die Leute ihn Sachen fragen, mich können die Leute aus dem anderen Stream fragen oder umgedreht,
das wäre glaube ich gar nicht mal schlecht, er hat ja auch was raus gekriegt am Ende, nutzt ihr
Display Link Docs auf der Arbeit, was ist Display Link, also mein Display auf der Arbeit hat einen
ganz normalen Displayport Anschluss, Display Link, ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist also benutzen wir
nicht, keine Ahnung, ist das irgendein Wireless Kram?
Wo ist er eigentlich? Jetzt haben wir gerade von ihm gesprochen.
Das mag sein, aber was meinst du wie der Durchschnitts-EQ erst überall sonst auf Twitch ist?
Schaust du eigentlich Live-Overflow ab und zu mal?
Wie lange kann man Kacken, naja wenn man auf dem Notebook dabei sitzt und eine Halterung hat,
dann kann man wahrscheinlich ganz schön lang auf dem Klo sitzen und dabei programmieren,
weiß ich was sie damals gemacht haben, aber wie gesagt es gibt Konferenz Talks und sowas
von den ehemaligen It's Soft Leuten bei der Entwicklung von Quake und allem möglichen das
die auf dem Klo gesessen haben, programmiert haben und geschissen haben, das erwarte ich
ja von gar keinem Entwickler heutzutage, HannesSurf danke für den Sub, Prime-Abo nutzen, ja beste
Wahl, Massive, any Primers, Prime-Subscription ist eh das beste, falls ihr das noch nicht wusstet
man kann nämlich mit einer Prime-Subscription so wie der Hannes das gerade gemacht hat, also wo
wir gerade wieder beim Thema sind, Mercify IQ im Chat wieder, also wer besonders High IQ ist lässt
seine Prime-Subscription nicht verfallen, sondern gibt sie einem Streamer seiner Wahl um ihn zu
supporten, zum Beispiel an mich, aber muss natürlich nicht, aber lasst sie nicht verfallen,
weil jede verfallene Prime-Subscription ist quasi eine Überweisung an Bezos selbst,
Starbucks 85, Dankeschön für den Prime-Subs, das funktioniert schon, jetzt bist du in der
Abo fallen, jetzt hast du vorbei, jetzt kommst du nicht mehr raus, bist du quasi im Schneeballsystem
gefangen, wie bei KLS jetzt, einmal Sub, immer Sub, musst du hustlen, hustlen wir, nee nicht
hustlen, hustlen, musst du dann, um auf den Mount Everest zu kommen. Yantari, Dankeschön für den Sub und
Flenick, schön dass ihr da seid Leute, jetzt kommt sogar noch das Scam Train an Start, den gibt's ja
nicht mal, jetzt hat der Boost Train, ja stimmt schon, hast schon recht, ich hab mich mit Overwatch
2.0 beschäftigt bisher, ich hab's noch nicht mal installiert, obwohl Free Game, ja man weiß ja nie,
hab's gleich geschafft Leute, Chat, ja zu Recht, ich hab's geschafft, ich bin unten im Chat,
Wahnsinn, nach 1 Stunde 20 Stream hab ich es geschafft im Chat zu lesen bis zum Schluss,
frag mal die Bahn, bei der Bahn wäre der Halbterm immer losgefahren, Moins Jelle,
bei der Bahn würden wir drauf warten, da müsst ihr jetzt überweisen und morgen könnt ihr das dann
sehen, also jetzt Subscriben und morgen, morgen wenn überhaupt, wird man es dann sehen, du hast
den FFZ, dein Highlight, das heißt ich hab jetzt gar nicht gesehen, was einer Wubblors geschrieben
hat, MonkaS, Highlight, Erscheinungsbild, nee Moment wo geht denn das, meine Augen,
Chat, Erscheinungsbild, nee Erwähnung heißt das, Erwähnung glaub ich, allgemein, Erwähnung im Chat
mit der Farbe, Nachrichten hervorheben die mich erwähnen, alles klar probiert mal aus Chat,
add Wubblors, ist jetzt funktioniert, nee, funktioniert nicht, warum nicht,
Ach Erwähnungsfarbe, ah, ok, Moment ich Refresh mal,
Hä, und warum ist der Dark Mode vor allem wieder aus,
ist, ist anscheinend kaputt,
aber bei mir auf dem zweiten Bildschirm seid ihr rot, jaja,
ach so ich bin ja nicht eingeloggt, Chat, Low IQ, da brauche ich noch ein bisschen mehr Prime
Subs, also muss ich jetzt sagen Wubblors, Text und dann Farbe, rot, ganze Wörter abgleichen,
Groß und Kleinschreibung beachten, ja, add Wubblors muss es dann sein, add Wubblors hinzufügen,
ah, sieht die Farbe kacke aus, man, ein bisschen dunkler sein, hat er das jetzt nicht gecheckt,
ich glaube das aktualisiert, ich glaube das aktualisiert nicht, das ist ja eklig,
wir machen das mal so, dass es nicht ganz so krass abartig ist, ok, was ist hier los Twitch,
Mensch, so, ok, das geht noch halbwegs, alles klar, jetzt erkenne ich wieder was, nice, ok,
gut, ja, funktioniert, ok, lass mal gucken, haben wir noch irgendwas, also ich bin jetzt
ungefähr noch eine halbe Stunde an, haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir gucken können,
was haben wir denn hier, Latency Numbers Programmers Should Know, das klingt nicht so spannend,
I built a massive cat wall, also quasi ein Kratzbaum, ein riesen Kratzbaum, ah ja, das
können wir uns irgendwann mal angucken, Ultimate Home Lab Tour, Alter, was hat denn der für
eine riesen Villa, mit Springbrunnen und so davor, was ist das, sind das Krakone Grundstückspreise,
10 free software, you probably don't know exist, ok, lie detection questions, was mir
Youtube wieder alles empfohlen hat, ok, ich guck mir mal die Home Lab Tour an, von Daves
Garage, wo man sich immer noch drüber streitet, ist es Garage, je nachdem, wen du fragst,
ist es was anderes, Alter, was eine riesen Hütte, Mensch, na gut, der Typ war glaube
ich ex Microsoft, fragt mich nicht, Typ, der hat massig Kohle, Alter, jetzt übertreib
mal, ok, so sieht es aus, wenn man zu viel Geld hat, moin Dave, also wenn du so reich
werden willst bei Microsoft, da musst du quasi DOS programmiert haben, what the fuck, Retro
Computer Museum, warum, warum muss es ausgerechnet Unify sein, ist das nicht, doch, das könnte
der Typ sein, der den Task Manager programmiert hat, den ursprünglichen, doch, doch, kann
sein, ok, zeige ich her, ok, mein ich schon, krasses Zeug, Kassetten Recorder, jetzt geht
es los, nein, erstmal schön bei den Autos durchgezoomt mit der Kamera, aber gut, ich
meine, wer hat, der hat, ganz ehrlich, soll er doch flexen, das ist doch ok, Alter, ok,
der Typ hat halt Millionen gemacht bei Microsoft, so wie es aussieht, da kriegt man halt einfach
ein Grundstück mit vier Häusern und allem, ja, ich frage mich, was ist das, was ist das,
was die alle archivieren, ganz ehrlich, ich archiviere meine Videos doch nicht, warum soll
ich meine Videos archivieren, die meisten Videos liegen bei mir auf einer CNT Platte
rum, weil ich auf die Renderer und zu faul bin regelmäßig zu löschen, aber ich sehe
nicht einfach, warum ich meine Videos archivieren sollte, du archivierst auch die Videos, das
ist ja auch was anderes, ich archiviere meine Streams, weil die weg sind auf Twitch nach
einer Weile, beziehungsweise der Max macht das, aber YouTube verschwindet ja nichts.
Einfach 25 Gig, ich kriege meine 10 Gig schon, hat irgendwie sinnvoll verwendet, aber 25
ist
into just write a big check and have a system integrator come in and do everything professionally.
And while that's certainly an option and no doubt the best choice for some folks,
I'm more of a change-your-own kind of oil-guy, so it didn't suit my nature.
I want to do it myself and tinker, and more importantly, learn a lot as I went.
It meant mistakes would be made, and even some money wasted from time to time,
but all in exchange for learning the best way to build out a massive home network infrastructure.
Wann wir innen gefahren sind, habe ich, was ich mir anstelle, einiges von euch gemacht, aber das hat er bestimmt trotzdem nicht alles komplett selbst gemacht. Ich glaube, der hat das selbst
designt, also quasi was er sich kaufen will, was wie wohin sind, da hat er schon leute beauftragt fürs kabel
kabel ziehen anschließen und alles, der wird nicht jeden eisenschrank selbst gebaut haben
Ich habe einen network switch mit 24 porten gekauft, um die Räume, die Hardware Internet benötigen, und dann habe ich den Rest mit einem Wifi-Router
Ich habe meinen Wifi-Builder mit einem Klassiker angefangen. Wo geht es denn los?
W-R-T 54 g alter das ding hatte gläder glaube ich mal, wenn er alt genug ist
Now this is a router that I've likely had a dozen of over the years
We even stored them in the break room freezer for some reason at my old company. I guess just we always know where the
Ich glaube, der kann bloß
n also
Moment I triple e
Nee, was ist was ist wlan 802.11 n oder
Ja das das hatte das ding von 2009 kommt schon hin
Since you couldn't link access points at the time my solution was to give each one its own ssid
As long as your phone can man machen kann man machen ja
Meine maus fast runter geschmissen
Kann man machen ich persönlich bevorzuge es bei mir alles mit der gleichen ssid zu haben dass die geräte gescheite rohmen können
Gibt manchmal probleme aber bei mir daheim ist es ja alles einmal
So ich habe zwei exis points haben exis point im keller und exis point im ersten stock
einer relativ zentral und einer ziemlich
auf der seite das habe ich aber auch nur aus einem grund
Weil manche geräte im keller zu schlechtes
wlan
on board wahrscheinlich die antenne zu klein ist
Um eine stabile verbindung mit dem exis point hier oben zu kriegen
Ja das stimmt das stimmt das ist in der heutigen zeit tatsächlich etwas angenehmer
Wenn du exis point hast die gescheites roaming unterstützen
Also das ist dann glaube ich 802.11r und 802.11d
Wenn ich es richtig im kopf habe
Warum warum weiß ich wlan standards eigentlich aus dem kopf ich habe damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun
Ja das hat was mit roaming zu tun und das hat glaube ich auch was mit roaming zu tun
Ne dann habe ich mich vertan aber er ist auf jeden fall was mit roaming
Also er ist 802.11r ist glaube ich diese geschichte dass die exis point
also dass ich die endgeräte schon zu neun genau hier steht es doch dass die sich zum nächsten
exis point verbinden noch bevor sie die verbindung zum alten kappen so dass man quasi schneller
und besser roaming kann wlan ist echt schwarze magie leute sage ich euch
Wie der cringe wer kein 10 gigabit in seinem schlafzimmer hat
Stimmt es dass alexas ein eigenes netzwerk mit alexas in der nähe haben
Keine ahnung technisch möglich wäre das natürlich
Weiß nicht machbar ist es da muss es aber schon sehr in der nähe sein
Weil so groß ist die wlan reichweite nicht
Der hat bestimmt ordentliche stromrechnung aber ich glaube das juckt den nicht
Ah da warste tür
der hat einfach triple ausfallssicheres internet kabelsatellit und was ist andere dsl oder was
Okay da muss es muss halt genug geld haben ich habe meinen zweiten telekom anschluss
ich habe den telekom anschluss mittlerweile abgestellt weil es unsinniges geld raus
geschmeißen war klar wurde manchmal probleme aber für die vier fünf mal im jahr wo ich
für eine halbe stunde vielleicht den telekom anschluss gebraucht hätte und das meistens
zu zeiten ist wo ich gar nichts von mit bekomme da war es mir das nicht wert irgendwie 70
euro noch mal im monat zu bezahlen
ah da war es mir das nicht wert irgendwie 70 euro noch mal im monat zu bezahlen
in die vier große Pannele, die zusammenkommen in der Sicherheitsklosur.
Auf der anderen Seite ist ein unifiniertes Video-Monitoring-Setup für unser eigenes Zuhause
und ein komplett besonderes Setup von Kameras auf einer detaillierten Netzwerke, die remotely...
Ah, eine Cyber-Power-USV, okay. Und ein Rauchmelder.
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Rauchmelder da oben.
...monitortiert von einem Sicherheitsteam.
Natürlich, die Ironie ist, dass...
Moment, der hat ein eigenes Security-Team?
Was sein Haus überwacht?
...Häuser sind immer noch...
Na gut, der Typ hat so viel Geld und so viele Häuser, da brauchen wir das wahrscheinlich.
...Wer weiß?
Easy Money!
Ah.
Die mag ich nicht.
Aber jeder, was er will.
Aber...
Die mag ich nicht, wow.
Doch.
Aha, die mag ich nicht, aber jeder was er will, aber die mag ich nicht, die Dream Machine.
Der Typ hat den Windows Task Manager programmiert.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ja, ja, ich weiß, wobei man ehrlicherweise sagen muss so ein Task Manager zu
programmieren ist jetzt nicht krasses Hexenwerk, allerdings den ersten Task Manager zu programmieren
und alles was dran hängt, dass ein Task Manager funktioniert, das ist wieder was ganz anderes.
Sind die Roten Kabel PoE Kabel?
Stimmt.
Das könnte eine Funktion sein, wenn man die Power Limits an der SFP-Plus-Porte aufbaut.
Ich weiß es nicht wirklich.
Schön beschriftet.
Ich habe auch Beschriftungen bei mir hinten im Raum, aber nicht so schön.
Und bei mir ist es lediglich Keller 1-2, Wohnzimmer 1-2 und sowas.
Nicht so...
etc....
144 terabytes of storage
This nas contains a daily backup of the main data from the studio nas so that all of my video content is backed up in
multiple formats in different physical locations
The main server closet also contains an alarm panel as well as the telco
tp link ja das meiste ist halt ziemlich low-end kram aber reicht für die meisten leute aus
die haben auch ein bisschen bisschen teurere sachen
aber tp link ist ja hauptsächlich so für für besonders niedrig preisiges netzwerkequipment bekannt kann man benutzen
Man darf jetzt keine wundervon erwarten ja aber in der regel für daheim reicht
Was habe ich gegen unify
Ich mag das juni ich hatte selbst eine ganze weile unify kram vor allem an die die ganzen vier access points verteilt über das
gesamte grundstück aber ich muss sagen ich finde unify ist irgendwie nichts halbes und nix ganzes
Und eben auch man muss unify verwenden mit unify also es geht schlecht mit was anderem zusammen aber sonst ist es nix halbes und nix ganzes
gerade das web interface vom unify wlan controller auf der einen seite
sind die sachen
nicht alle da die man haben möchte in
ist aber in für in in hochpreis preisige equipment fehlt einiges an features
wie zum beispiel
dpsk oder sowas in der richtung
und auf der anderen seite
ist es gar nicht so ganz klar was was
macht
also es gab viele seien ist dass das hat sich für mich wenigsthalbes und nix ganzes angefühlt
also weiß ich ich ich bin kein großer unify fan mehr
Ich habe alle meine unify access points abgebaut mittlerweile und durch einen anderen hersteller ersetzt
Das will ich euch jetzt aber nicht pauschal empfehlen weil das unify zeug ist für den preis schon ok das kann man sich kaufen
Ich habe jetzt gebrauchte wlan access points von einem anderen hersteller, die habe ich auf ebay gekauft wie gesagt gebraucht
kosten selbst auf ebay noch
ähnlich viel wie unify neu beziehungsweise teilweise sogar ein ticken mehr aber ich bin damit deutlich also viel viel viel zufriedener als mit dem unify zeug
Ich habe keinerlei probleme mit meinen kameras und sonst was es geht einfach alles wunderbar
Also wenn es interessiert ich habe gerade
Einen davon
Und einen davon
Ihr dürft euch jetzt natürlich nicht die preise angucken was der krempel neu kostet das natürlich komplett der blödsinn
Ihr müsst auf ebay gucken auf ebay bezahlt man ungefähr für so einen access point so für den großen so
250 euro oder so gebraucht
Ja, das ist alles alles blödsinn vergesst man kauft da für keiner
Ja, so was hier so in dem halt nicht unbedingt aus nicht von den amis das ist bisschen bisschen teuer
Mal gucken uk gibt es auch öfters mal welche zu kaufen
Standort europäische union können wir machen
Gibt gerade nichts muss man muss man ungefähr muss man abwarten vielleicht gibt es mittlerweile auch schon die neueren zu kaufen
Das ist ein bisschen teuer
Müssen wir mal gucken und ich muss ehrlich sagen damit bin ich deutlich zufrieden jetzt wirklich viel viel viel zufriedener als mit dem unify kram
Ja, das ist ein bisschen teuer
Ja, damit bin ich deutlich zufrieden jetzt wirklich viel viel viel zufriedener als mit dem unify kram
Oh nee jetzt werdet ihr wieder irgendwelche komischen channels gespammt gleich mal bannen leute
Alles alles weg
Möchte eventuell ein tp link manage switch holen warum also warum willst du ein manage switch was hast du vor willst du vlans verwenden oder aus welchen gründen muss es ein manage switch sein
Manage switch ist nicht einfach besser nur weil er managt ist wenn man damit nichts spezielles machen will was ich dir empfehlen würde hol dir wenn du ein bisschen was gescheites haben willst mit dem du auch vieles
Machen kannst und vielleicht ein bisschen was lernen willst über netzwerks sachen
Dann hole dir einen mikrotik switch
Dann hol dir einen mikrotik switch
Gibt es relativ günstig sogar schon
10 gig beziehungsweise
Auch relativ günstig 24 ports wie macht man 10 giga genauso wie jegliches andere netzwerk
ist überhaupt ist eigentlich überhaupt kein unterschied du brauchst einen switch der 10 gig kann
sfp oder also sfp plus oder oder ajot 45 du brauchst netzwerkkarten in einem rechner die das können
und du brauchst halt
irgendein anwendungszweck für also du brauchst auch die passende hardware dafür also wenn du jetzt einfach nur nass hast mit einer magne festplatte dran oder so oder selbst selbst wenn ich
selbst mit der ssd dran bringt dir das nichts also brauchst du die entsprechende hardware dass sich das lohnt
Aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich kein unterschied zu normalem netzwerk also was es mit steckdose zu tun hat verstehe ich jetzt nicht genau
Ach so du meinst so in doch doch doch
wie gesagt
wenn du normale kabel bei dir im haus hast mit ajot 45 stecker geht das auch also 10 gigabit geht über ajot 45 stecker und sfp plus module allerdings sfp plus module sind in der regel ein bisschen
Strom sparen da das ist aber nicht das ding
sfp plus module in form von direct attach kabeln sind auch billiger weil die sfp ports also die sfp plus ports sind meistens etwas billiger bei switchen wie die ajot 45 kumper ports
also du kriegst einen 12 port switch mit sfp plus für wenigstens 12 port switch
mit ajot 45 kabel mit ajot 45 stecker aber du kannst es wahrscheinlich sogar mit der ganz normalen verkabelung in deinem haus in deinem in deinem haus verwenden
ich weiß aus dem kopf nicht was die offiziellen anforderungen sind
für was man mindestens haben muss an kabel und alles aber die chance dass es über kurze strecken mit deiner aktuellen verkabelung funktioniert ist recht hoch
in deinem lahnkorb habe ich keine ahnung von
ja wenn schon mal mit router os dann kannst du alles mögliche mitmachen
also ich wie gesagt ich weiß aus dem kopf nicht was die da die offiziellen sachen sind aber die beziehen sich die beziehen sich ja auf 100 meter kabel
10 gig über 2 3 meter kabel geht wahrscheinlich über die letzte mülleitung
solange solange nicht die isolierung irgendwie schon raus raus guckt oder so
überstromt so was wie d-laden oder so nicht dass er wieder was ganz was anderes ja
also es gibt okay ich erzähle euch das jetzt mal es gibt fertige switches mit aj 45 kabeln
was habe zähle ich mit kabeln es gibt selbstverständlich 10 gigabit switches mit aj 45 steckern natürlich das ist ja eines der hauptdinger wie man das macht
ich persönlich finde die kombination aus sfp plus ports und kumper ports ganz nice weil du hast die option auch mal ein bisschen was
ja was soll ich eigentlich eigentlich brauchst du es nicht wirklich aber wie gesagt sfp plus ports sind meistens ein bisschen billiger in der in der menge zu bekommen
mal ganz davon abgesehen du brauchst kein modul an jedem sfp port du kannst ein modul an den sfp port anschließen wenn du glasfaserkabel verwenden willst
die module brauchst du nur wenn du glasfaserkabel verwenden willst wenn du direkt attach kabel verwenden willst dann brauchst du das nicht
dann brauchst du das nicht wenn du sowas verwenden willst dann brauchst du es nicht da ist es nämlich schon dran guck da
das gibt es bis zu 10 meter ich glaube maximal 10 meter geht das und die kannst du einfach einstecken und gut ist das funktioniert dann ähnlich
wie so normales netzwerkabel du brauchst halt auf beiden seiten ansonsten brauchst du module wenn du glasfaser verwenden willst
aber normalerweise würde ich kein glasfaser verwenden wenn wenn du nicht die die die strecke die die die länge da irgendwie brauchst
wenn du jetzt natürlich aus irgendwelchen gründen dein gartenhäuschen verkabeln willst oder ein glasfaserkabel gelegt hast ja warum nicht
da stell ich mir eklig vor
ich würde eh das benutzen was da ist ich würde nicht neu bohren
also kannst du höchstwahrscheinlich deine dosen weiter verwenden
musst du gucken es gibt hier kannst du auf geizhals filtern und gucken ich persönlich mag kein mikrotik switches und router aber es gibt genug 10 gig router mit 845 ports mittlerweile
ohai IQ comment hier wieder ja das klingt logisch
so wir gucken das video jetzt mal von ihm fertig
wo sie überstehen geblieben da
das ist mir jetzt egal was er da mit seinem kabelmotor macht alter was ein wohnzimmer man die haus kostet wahrscheinlich mehr als hier mein gesamtes wohnzimmer
also
Ja sonder du hast recht MikroTik ist von der Bedienung her schon ein bisschen
Sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig auch die WLAN config und alles
Aber es ist halt finde ich preisleistungstechnisch unschlagbar
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, aber das Wohnzimmer interessiert mich jetzt nicht so
Was zum Teufel hat er da denn?
Warum?
Einfach mal Kassetten sind
Na dann
Die Couch sieht teuer aus, ich weiß nicht genau, wie ich das festmache, aber die Couch sieht teuer aus.
Also, mein Lieblingsspot war etwas, was ich glaube, das coolste Teil dieses Set-ups war.
Ein einziger Thunderbolt Kabel, das mein Laptop bringt, 120 Watt Power, eine PcI Raid Cage und 10 Gigabit Zugang zu dem Rest der Lande und dem Studio NAS.
Es ist ziemlich viel, was ich...
Hat Glück, dass er nicht mehr bei Microsoft arbeitet, da darf er jetzt gescheite Hardware verwenden.
Die Thunderbolt und die USB-C-Standards haben gespart.
Das Haus sieht nicht nur teuer aus, das ist insgesamt teuer als Fakt. Der Typ hat vier Häuser auf seinem Grundstück, Mann.
Oh, Dankeschön Herr Pandora für den Raid.
Ja, schön, dass ihr hier seid.
Ich bin genau noch eine Minute online.
Bester Zeitpunkt für den Raid.
22 Uhr ist bei mir immer Boomer muss Schlafen Zeit.
Nein, ich wollte eigentlich das Video noch fertig gucken von ihm.
Also aus dem Danke für den Host.
Du musst über Stunden machen, ja.
Okay, jetzt zeig mal deinen Rechner-Set-up.
Ist das ein Samsung?
Ungefähr so sieht mein Monitor auf der Arbeit aus.
Da hab ich genau, also fast genau so ein Ding stehen.
So einen riesigen Curved-Monitor.
Und...
Oh nee, jetzt spackt Wunderform wieder, oder?
Ich glaub, die wollen, dass ich off gehe.
Nee, jetzt geht's wieder.
Ähm...
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Genau, so einen Teil hab ich auf der Arbeit auch.
Ja, für mich ist das riesig.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, zwei Einzel werden mir lieber.
Käsebällchen.
Ja, das ist schon praktisch, aber trotzdem, mir wären zwei Einzel lieber.
Weil so ist es halt ein großer Bildschirm.
Und wenn du halt, wie ich, Tiling-Window-Manager verwendest,
dann ist dann halt, bäm, so ein riesen Terminal drauf.
Da muss ich's quasi dann erst mal teilen und dann immer dahinschieben,
wo ich gerne meinen Monitorgrenze hätte.
Also mir persönlich wären zwei Bildschirme in dem Fall tatsächlich lieber.
Könnte ich zwei Desktops aufmachen auf jeweils einem Bildschirm.
Und ich mein, ich könnte wahrscheinlich,
wenn ich das auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall
ich könnte wahrscheinlich den Bildschirm so einstellen, dass er als zwei verschiedene Bildschirme gilt.
Da bin ich aber nicht sicher, ob er noch weiter über einen Displayportkabel funktioniert.
Also ich persönlich hätte zwei lieber.
Aber ich will mich jetzt nicht beschweren, wenn man so ein Ding schon hingestellt bekommt.
Dann, ja, kann man sich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Gibt Apps die Fenster automatisch positionieren?
Ja, das mag sein.
Aber bestimmt nicht für E3 und für Tiling Winner Manager.
Und selbst dann wär's mir einfach lieber, weil ich ja nicht immer exakt die gleichen Apps
unbedingt an den gleichen Stellen haben will.
Aber ich sag zum Beispiel, hey, ich möchte jetzt mal was, was ich meinen Teams rüberschieben
auf den anderen Desktop, weil ich auf irgendwas warte oder so.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab schon öfters gehabt, dass ich mir gedacht habe auf der Arbeit,
hey, zwei Monitore wären mir lieber gewesen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich will mich nicht beschweren.
...
... ist trotzdem recht gut.
Okay, weiter im Text.
Was hat er als nächstes am Start?
Ordentlich RGB.
Mich interessiert eigentlich eher mehr seine Racks, falls er die nochmal zeigt.
...
Entscheidlich.
Videoschnitt sind auf Breitenmonitoren einfach besser?
Ja, okay, stimmt, aber ich mach ja keinen Videoschnitt auf der Arbeit.
...